ah
i
la trata de seres humanos es el negocio
criminal más rentable del mundo datos
oficiales de las naciones unidas
muestran que el 70 por ciento de las
víctimas son mujeres brasil es un país
de origen de tránsito y de destino de
personas traficadas además de la
tradicional explotación sexual las
autoridades locales registran cada vez
más casos de esclavitud sólo entre el
año 2017 el año 2020 fueron liberadas en
brasil- cerca de 16 mil personas que
trabajaban en condiciones equivalentes a
la esclavitud el 72 por ciento serán
negras lo que demuestra que además de
los factores de pobreza y desempleo el
factor racial es determinante a la hora
de definir esta lacra
[Música]
la trata de personas se puede definir
como el comercio ilegal y la
instrumentalización violenta de seres
humanos en situación de vulnerabilidad
para fines de explotación es una lacra
que afecta a millones de personas en el
mundo y según los datos de las naciones
unidas- tres cuartas partes del total de
víctimas son mujeres y dentro de la
complejidad de las redes de trata se
distingue claramente que la mayoría de
víctimas proceden del sur global y son
explotadas en países del norte y países
de tránsito y es que la trata de
personas está estrechamente vinculada a
los procesos migratorios irregulares y a
la limitación del derecho a la movilidad
de las personas en la mayoría de casas
las víctimas de trata no han tenido
acceso a vías legales y seguras para
llegar a su destino que suelen ser
lugares con un régimen de fronteras muy
restringido como es el caso de eeuu o de
la unión europea y aquí en la región del
magreb y concretamente en marruecos en
la mayoría de víctimas de trata son
efectivamente las personas migrantes
procedentes en este caso de áfrica
sub-sahariana que se ven abocadas a la
mendicidad forzada y sometidas a redes
de explotación sexual y laboral en su
tránsito migratorio hacia europa
[Aplausos]
[Música]
existe un boyante mercado de trata de
novias en china que sufren tanto las
señas minoritarias como sobre todo los
países pobres del entorno asiático viene
a suplir el déficit de mujeres en china
que algunos estudios cifran en 30
millones y que ha sido provocado por la
política del hijo único vigente durante
décadas y por la predilección por el
varón en las sociedades rurales
tradicionales así que para cumplir con
el deber confuciano de la descendencia
los más desesperados recurren a estas
mafias del sudeste asiático que traen a
las mujeres con falsas promesas de
trabajo los países de origen son
tailandia laos mianmar o vietnam alertan
las organizaciones de derechos humanos
que la crisis económica provocada por el
coronavirus ha hecho a las mujeres
todavía más vulnerables y también
alertan de que las mafias están
aprovechando las convulsiones provocadas
por el golpe de estado en mianmar para
operar con más libertad
[Música]